lands back at it the celebrity madness
hitting a whole new level with their
latest attacks against President Trump
here is a late-night talk-show host Seth
Meyers
Trampas totally incoherent and capable
of telling the truth he shouldn't get to
address the nation just to repeat his
lies if he calls up the network's asking
for airtime they should pick up the
phone and say President Trump we don't
know who that is
tough guy Robert De Niro continuing his
attacks now calling Trump a quote white
supremacist and a real racist who is bad
for the country an actor samuel
l.jackson jumping on the bandwagon
tweeting his endorsement of
congresswoman recede to leaves use of
extreme profanity to describe the
president David do you notice a
difference in the assaults on the
President of the United States compared
to George W Bush but they didn't call
him a white supremacist that was that
was not it but it was really had to do
with the war and there was a lot of
anger and frustration after the recount
I mean that I'm not excusing any of it
but it was policy driven it seems like
cuz the war really agitated a lot of
people not the thing where george w
bush's i said he was stupid right right
they that everyone thought they were
smarter than he was do they think that
about President Trump today I'm sure
that they do and this is interesting for
like for Hollywood for me I've just I've
never been enamored with it
like if you asked me like who would you
most like to have dinner with I would
never choose somebody from Hollywood it
just doesn't I don't want to actually
get to know them I don't think that what
they have to say is all that interesting
in fact what they mostly say like for
example on the white supremacist piece
or in repeating the expletive against
the president last week it just shows
like a real lack of ability to think
Greg do you um do you just like the fact
that you have favorite actors like a
Samuel Jackson or Robert De Niro who you
loved their movies but then when they
tell of politics you're like oh my gosh
what is it it's disappointing because it
tells you two things that the the the
most outspoken in Hollywood think alike
because it's lockstep and the people you
don't hear from you can assume are
conservative because they're not talking
so it's all run and in a skit this is
not to your point about
bush this is not new all right I mean it
just truck Trump just happens to be the
latest trigger and all of this and he's
a proxy for half the country that
Hollywood looks down they don't like
Trump they don't like half the country
the first one but I gotta tell ya they
you know she'd send roses every day to
Donald Trump George Takei aka Sulu Sulu
who now is a new TV show and it's not
because of what his career has been
because I know I don't remember him
being in on anything since Star Trek but
it's his Trump triggered tweets
yeah and that is breathed new life into
took George Takei and he's actually kind
of funny but my point is a lot of these
people oh it's a Trump because they were
they were nowhere now they're somewhere
Juan do you think this kind of you know
these kind of slanderous statements
against the president outrageous they
get on Fox News do you think that makes
a democratic party as a whole look bad
so who I mean obviously it's subjective
but I mean I guess you're just you know
to average Americans independence people
that are not language if that's what you
mean and obviously you know you sit next
to me but you know I don't like the
bullying I don't like the personal
attacks that the president engages and I
think imitating that behavior is not
attractive to me and I don't think it's
attractive to most people but I don't
mean obviously some people's excuse it
and say a big deal not to them I will
say this I think the big issue here is
not somehow that there are Hollywood
elites that people like or don't like
it's that people are saying this
president lies constantly tonight the
worry is he's gonna lie again tell more
lies and then people get frustrated and
angry and use profanity but I mean I
would just come back to the actual issue
let's stick to the facts let's not make
up stories in order to justify actions
of a tyrant let's not do that well I
think the president will be fact-checked
by his own staff and by the mainstream
media never happened to a bomb I don't
see the tyrant analogy one but let's
move on to Emily when you look at these
celebrities saying these things do you
think they have as much influence as
they used to or any people just tune
them out no definitely not and I think
that's statistically proven right now
that in terms of like the younger
generation that
much more profound influencers are
youtube and internet sensations whose
names we would we wouldn't recognize but
God felt to me you know the common theme
of Hollywood and in the Hollywood vs.
Trump is just the hypocrisy it's
ridiculous to me for this kind of
insular community that has the highest
like for example the highest level of
homelessness into the in the entire
United States with the highest median of
housing you know it's almost a million
dollars and these are the guys saying
that the the guy in the Oval Office is
the one perpetuating a polarized society
or that he's the one that doesn't care
about low-income or mine minority
communities and one of the quotes that
we read by Alexandria Ocasio Cortez that
says the GOP lost entitlement to police
scene women's behavior a long time ago
Oh like in this regard like Hollywood
still has that honor like oh that's
right because women have been respected
economically and sexually and in the in
the market all around by Hollywood this
entire time so I just every time a
celebrity opens their mouth with just
such a vitriol that isn't policy based I
just think there is a question if
they're more influential now I think if
they were influential Hillary Clinton
would be present that's true that jay-z
and Beyonce rally would have put her
over Katy Perry yeah and remember every
every mouth that was espousing that
stuff about Trump kissed Harvey
Weinstein's ass let's look sleepy with
that salt America